everybody lives in North America here
right um we don't have everybody living
outside of the North American continent
so the laws are pretty much consistently
the same here they're generally hostile
towards the person that's the bread
winner um in the
household um they generally protect the
person that gives birth I'm not going to
say person but the mother they generally
protect the mother I don't like these
terms person person of birthing
capabilities or some [__] like that
mother yeah birthing person or some
garbage like that mothers are generally
protected um if you were dating a guy
that you like you dig his Vibe you want
to claim him um you know you've had the
word do we stand talk other guys are
invisible to you you want to be with
them but he starts setting some
boundaries around how you're going to
live your lives together maybe
separately separately an together sort
of thing you know I've seen versions of
you know I mentioned ear like I've seen
versions of of people trying to blend
their lives but they still kept keep a
separation to it because it just seems
to work better uh for a variety of
reasons is that something that you
ladies would make a concession on or
would it have to be like a conventional
one man one woman one household children
all Al together like are you open to
concessions is that something that you
would look at I feel like it's every
person that you're with or like
especially because I'm single every
person that I'm in a date or like I have
been on dates with like they're all
different and so like yes like I've gone
on a couple dates with one guy and like
I'm getting starting getting to know him
obviously I don't know him like really
that well but from what I'm getting from
him is I could
honestly you know far down the road I
could honestly like we would be a team
you know like it would be a what
whatever we both want and I would you
know love to hear what he has to say and
then I feel like he would do the same
okay so let me so let me rephrase that a
little bit differently sort of like deal
with the subject matter of like the team
right um are men and women equal like
are we the same
um when it comes to long relationship
marries but when you get into
details but when you get into the yes we
are equal if you want to say it just
flat out like that but at the same time
there are things men do better in in
stats or there and there are things that
women do better or can do better and so
it's just like it everyone has their
weaknesses everyone has their strengths
and I feel like when you say team though
like like like like teams have different
players you've got like in football you
got quarterbacks you got the kicker you
got the coach you got the assisting
coach like everybody has a role so if
you could be a little bit more
definitive in the role of the team
members like for him and for her like
what are the roles um again it it I feel
like it's different with each
relationship but for like me what I've
gone through is you
know
it's we're more
like or like I don't even know how to
say that but like
um we're just we're s i we're each
other's Partners like we're like we
should be um there's no Captain or co-
captain we're both Co captains you know
like we there's
different there's one steering wheel in
a car and there's a passenger seat for
shotgun so where do you sit I'm sorry
what was that but there's one steering
wheel in a car and there's a passenger
seat for shotgun so where do you sit in
that car um if I don't feel like driving
that day I'll sit in the passenger but
you know if he doesn't feel like driving
that day he can sit in the passenger
it's so you're saying the roles can swap
like yeah of course of course yeah it
all depends on the relationship you know
and and if you have to I feel like it I
don't like the happy wife happy life or
or I don't like the king I mean I like
that one but like just like the you
don't hear any men saying that but it's
like okay let me just stop you for a sec
put that thought on hold off I know you
got something Laura when you go out with
your guy who ends up driving the car oh
him all the time G when you go out with
your guy who ends up driving the car
absolutely him will not let me drive
Selma if you get married who ends up
driving the car oh him Kaylee him
passenger princess all the way passenger
princess M go ahead no I mean I saw Gan
nodding and I wanted to get to her but I
I had a question for Kelly it's you know
this is this is often something I try to
float to somebody that says it's 50/50
or there's equal decision-making power
sort of in a relationship but let's say
the two of you are at complete a with
one another and you're not going to
change your position he's not going to
change his position and they're the
complete opposite how does a decision
get made in that scenario um so I've
actually my engagement that um was
broken off uh we got in many fights
towards the end and he where we didn't
come to a conclusion
but and it was embarrassing sometimes it
was it' be at restaurants or something
like that or
like and or it' be just like hurtful and
so I found out after you know rehashing
that whole relationship my brain as I
was trying to get over it as I am still
trying to get over it um
it's he walked away or I would walk away
I can't say that I was perfect or I'd
walk away we wouldn't communicate even
if there was NOC decision that was made
there we wouldn't communicate but I feel
like communication is key and I know
that's so like cliche and stupid to say
but communication really makes or breaks
everything like it's right but let's say
you're communicating like it's it seems
like the answer in the scenario is that
the relationship self-destructs right
you've got two people that are that are
making their positions known you sit
down you give your argument for the
decision that you think should be made
he gives his argument you know well
thought out and cogin for the decision
he thinks should be made and there you
two are on complete opposite sides of
the coin so you're saying a decision
doesn't get made and that the only
answer is that the relationship blows up
I mean how does a decision get made what
how do you choose to move forward how
does that path there's
been where I've just kind of like given
in and I just okay but then I eventually
you know it the relationship ends like
my engagement like there was a lot of
times because I left it we dated when we
were kids we met 10 years later we
thought it was fate um and he was he was
Lov my life and um it
was very toxic and ugly towards the end
I recorded a lot of our videos of him
just screaming at me I mean I mean so a
lot of times I just sat there and I just
took it and it was wrong with me um I'm
definitely you know a lot tougher but um
from that but it was just like a lot of
times I just had to compromise and I'm
not saying that all that only happens
with women I mean men do that too um so
I AG I mean it I feel like it's not okay
we're equal yes but it can fluctuate on
certain things either either you can do
better or your opinions on should a
should a marriage be led by somebody no
it shouldn't what do you think at times
yes at times yes but not in the whole
situ all the time like I mean I love
being the passenger princess don't get
me wrong but like if sometimes I like to
drive some I like to be in control so
it's it's like no no but I'm but I'm
asking generally speaking like in a
marriage like like should there should
there be a leader like like should
somebody lead that relationship I feel
like I'm
asking I really don't yeah I don't think
there should be because yall should
again y'all are co- captain and okay
everything if you communicate then
there's there doesn't have to be a
leader okay what about Selma and Kaylee
like what do you think about that notion
like is there is there somebody that
should lead that relationship and if so
who um yeah I mean I get that there is
balance in every connection and
things change dayto day different
seasons things can change but I
personally like I want my man my
masculine to be in his leader role and
let me be in my feminine role like that
doesn't mean that I don't take control
and have a stance and share my
communication and thoughts and needs and
everything like that but like I think
it's more natural for a guy to just be
that leader and like let me and I'm
still leading in my feminine but it's
just in a different way if that makes
sense and like just let him be that okay
that dominant role I don't I think
there's always like a a dominant and
submit submissive like energetics going
on like it's constantly at play and I
get that that can switch up but I think
it's just more natural for the guy to
like
be okay Selma what do you think you've
got some strong opinions
tonight um I always tell people I'm
looking for a man that allows me to step
into my
femininity um so I you know the old
saying of like the man is the head of
the household but the woman is the neck
that's kind of I think a perfect example
of kind of what other especially younger
generational women they tend to think
that oh in a marriage if a man is the
head of the household it takes all of
your power but that's not what a
successful Dynamic is so I would say I
believe in men being the head of the
households and making the primary mover
decisions and the woman is is
responsible for the secondary mover
decisions so he's so he's got a degree
of authority in the household and
responsibility to it then yeah and I
think there's also a you were mentioning
earlier I thought it was interesting um
about if a if a man said something and
you were just agreeing who would
basically win that argument kind of
sense and I think it's interesting to
hear that
because I have cultural differences as
well like my father is Pakistani so and
most of the men that I partner with are
all Muslim and in those cultures and
that type of society it's very much
patriarchal and very much like they make
the decision that is the way that it is
even via the government every aspect of
life um so then to see like even in us
if we're all in North America so to see
how that conversation is so different is
is interesting I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
line books and a bunch of other stuff
have an amazing day peace out